Hello everybody, I am Dr. Kevin Connors and we are talking about your genetic variants,
your genetic defects, and today's, this presentation is going to be an energy production.
I call it fighting the hidden causes of disease because many times this is like a hidden
piece, a gem that you discover that could be your final stone that you uttered that could
be, oh, that's why. When we talk about your mitochondrial genes, we're going to talk about this
presentation, there's a lot of, oh, that's why going out here because when you deal with
chronic fatigue patients, it's always very difficult to deal with them. Tell you
learn genetics and you start to get those aha moments, so it could really be a light bulb moment.
That's why I put a light bulb on this slide because many times when you look at your genetics,
it could be a light bulb moment, but if you watched the gut one, the first one I did,
if you watched that video, you will hear me howling the fact that it's not solely your genetics.
Environment plays a huge, if not, trumps completely the genetics, so it is really the environment
plus the genetics. It is the environment that tip to person over and to really see their genetic
defects because you've had these genetic defects since you were born. You just got your symptoms when
you turned 30 or when you had your last baby or whatever it was. It was the environment that
tipped you over so now you start to see really your genetic flaws. Now supporting these genetic flaws
can really help you get tipped back over and feeling much better. So these presentations presuppose
that you have already done or you're going to do your 23andMe profile. That's the lab you have to pay
for that through 23andMe. That's completely out of my hands. Go to 23andMe.com and order the complete
$199 Profiles. That's what the price it is as I'm taping this. Don't get the cheaper one. Get
the full one and then I need your user David Password in order to put it into our software to do this
application. So as you look at these slides, you can see that. So if you're looking at these slides and
you haven't purchased our interpretation of your 23andMe, it had me put it into the software,
my software, that had me give you a copy of that genetic defect profile. All this will look really
weird to you when I start showing you the pictures of your genetics because you don't see it on your 23andMe
because they don't give you that detail because they're not a clinic. They're not a clinician so they
can't legally give you a bunch of interpretation. So they have to be careful FDA-wise to not do that.
So if you're trying to skip by it, I'm just going to watch this guy's videos. If I don't see this
on my 23andMe, how come I don't see it? Because you're not getting the same step reported. I'd say you
have to buy my thing but go to somebody who knows how to interpret this for you then. So you could get
this detail. So in this presentation, we're talking about energy production. We're going to get some
detail. I'm not trying to uncover your flaws in human biology from high school but
where we have to get into this in a little bit of depth because it helps you understand that.
So when we're talking about energy production, we're talking about glycolysis or the crebs cycle
in oxidative phosphorylation, the euphatiasid cycle. That's what produces ATP. That's really what
energy is. And all your cells need ATP in order to do what it needs to do in order for muscles to
contract, it requires ATP. In order for all the cells to do what they need to do, they need ATP.
So all your cells have mitochondria in the cells. In order to produce ATP, it's not produced in a
certain spot to the distributed through the bloodstream. It's produced in the cell in order for that
cellular function to take place. And in the mitochondria, these little organelles inside the cells,
that's what's happening. This, the glycolysis, citric acid cycle or the crebs cycle, oxidative
phosphorylation, the fatty acid cycle, in order to spin out ATP so that cell could do what it's supposed
to do. So if you have inadequate production of ATP for multiple reasons and we're going to talk about
some of those in this presentation, then that cell isn't going to do what it's supposed to do.
And you're going to have symptoms based upon that cell's inability to do that.
So if my heart cells which have an enormous number of mitochondria compared to other cells because
your heart cells have to contract every second, if they're not able to produce the ATP or inadequate
about the ATP, you're going to have more heart, you're going to have more fatigue because your heart
is not going to pump at the same strength as it should be. And you're going to have more fatigue
completely based upon that. I mean physical fatigue, you're going to have muscle fatigue. If your
muscle cells can't produce ATP, they're going to fatigue out quickly. That's really what getting in shape
is. Getting in shape is technically your muscle cells' ability to convert, peruvate to acetyl
coenzyme to get into the crem cycle to produce ATP, the rate at which peruvate converts to acetyl coenzyme
to get into the crem cycle to produce ATP is what getting in shape is. So if I haven't run for a while
and I'm going to start running, it's like, oh my gosh, my legs are so sore, it's because peruvate
is converting to lactic acid. And that's what the pain in the soreness of my muscle is because
that rate limiting step of conversion for peruvate to acetyl coenzyme is very slow.
So as I keep working it, as I keep exercising as long as I have decent genes and as long as I
feed it by genes very well with the substrates needed for that conversion factor,
then but that rate of conversion for peruvate to acetyl coenzyme is quicker and I am getting quote,
in shape. So understand that? Good. We'll have a quiz on it at the end. So that's what we're talking
about. There are genetic components in each one of these steps. So you look at this picture of the
crem cycle. I talked about the upper piece there, peruvate acetyl coenzyme, quite briefly there,
but there's a whole bunch of different steps in each one of these conversion steps are depended
upon enzymes. Enzymes are made by genes. So that's what we're looking at. Do you have a lot of
defects on the genes that make these enzymes? Well, guess what? It's good to slow that conversion and
you can see it on tests like the genetic test, your 23 and B. I have the defect. And you can see it on
tests like an organic acid test. An organic acid test actually tests the substrates. And wow,
I have a lot of this substrate, but very little of the next step substrate and a hemogen defect,
what's supposed to convert substrate A to substrate B? Well, no wonder. Well, if I support that
step, it'll convert A to B more quickly and I will produce more ATP. Is that really rocket science
people? It's just looking at these conversion steps and looking at what A makes turns into B,
B turns into C, C turns into D. Are there limited factors of A turning into B and B turning into
C? Yes, there are. Well, let's find out what they are. Let's look at them. Okay, well, here's a
limited factor right here. Do we have a defect here? We have a decrease in subs. We have a decrease in
nutrients that help move that step. So let's play with that and you could make the world of
difference in a person's life. A lot to say, huh? So I'm trying to make this as uncomplicated as
possible. But I know there's a lot of steps. And if you don't have a science background and a science
mind, you might go, I don't get this. Listen to it a few times. You know, truthfully, honestly, you don't
have to get this. You don't have to become a functional medicine person. You don't have to
become a geneticist. Just take my recommendations then. But I bake these videos because I believe the
more informed you are, the better decisions you can make. And it helps you understand the recommendations
I'm making. I don't want to be the kind of doctor where a person comes to me and I say, here, just
take this prescription and give me the prescription and you go out and maybe that's not the best thing for
you. Plus, I know I cannot possibly communicate with every one of you. I can't. It's impossible. You can't
all come to my clinic. I can't run all these different tests on you. And I understand there's a lot
of information here. And your current local doctor might not understand this piece. That's okay.
But so if I can fill in the gaps there, then that's a beautiful thing. And you could take my
recommendations and I'm going to give you at the end that you can then take it back to your doctor
and you can go over or she can go over that or test you on those things or whatever. You can make
more or better informed decisions. That's a whole purpose of this. Okay. That's why it's not
expensive either. So I spent a lot of time teaching and making these videos. So please don't call
our office and be mad because you tried something that didn't work. You know, I didn't do an exam on
you. Okay. Please don't do that. That's very frustrated for me and my staff. What I feel like we
give a lot here. You know, download all my books for free. Download these videos. Utilize the information
I give you, but I can't possibly be everything to everybody. So when we look at energy production,
there's three phases. There's glycolysis. There's the creb cycle or citric acid cycle. And there's
the electron transport change, change, oxidative phosphorylation. So that's cell respiration. That's
how cells make energy. That's how cells work. So that's where we're going to kind of go through those
who are going to go through them quite quickly. So I'm going to try to give you a high school
college biology degree here. So you need NADH and FADH in order for oxidation to occur. In order for
you need an oxidizing agent in order for that's for oxidation to occur. You need a reducing agent
in order for reduction to occur. And understand we take a lot. We don't need oxidation in our body because
that's bad because that can cause cancer. So we need to take a whole bunch of antioxidants. So
chemical exposure causes oxidation. And that's not good. That causes cell death. So we need to take
a whole bunch of antioxidants to offset that chemical exposure. Remember what I've said in so
many slide presentations. Nothing is ever totally a bad thing. It's all about balance. Yeah, you could say,
well, it's consuming mercury a bad thing. Well, yeah, that is a bad thing. That's a heavy metal toxicity.
But truthfully, there's mercury, small TDM amounts in our soil, in our vegetables, in our water,
et cetera. It's when we are out of balance. When we consume too much of it. When we're exposed to
too much of something, when our body can take care of something, that's where the imbalance comes in.
And that's where we have dysfunction and disease. So it's all about balance. That's so much about
saying, this is a bad guy. This is a good guy. It's about saying too much of this is a bad guy. Too much of
this is a bad guy. That is normally a good guy. So taking too many antioxidants could actually be a
bad thing for people. It's all about balance. So the first, the understanding that we have co-ensimes
and enzymes in our body that make different things, NADH and FADH are considered co-ensimes that control
the function of our pathways. It's all about metabolic pathways in order to make energy.
So these are oxidizing agents and reducing agents. These are oxidants and antioxidants that
donate electrons that take electrons in order for things to move. It's all about motion. Life is
motion. And these pathways have to be moving where these pathways start to slow down because of
rate limiting factors. That's when disease starts to set in. That's when symptoms start to set in.
So your body takes glucose from our foods and it has to keep it into the cells, get it into the
mitochondria in order for glycolysis to take place, in order for the crebs cycle to take place,
in order for oxidative phosphorylation to take place, in order for you to make ATP. I've said it before,
that is what are your life goals. That's what if your life purpose is. You don't have a life
purpose. Well, here's your life purpose to make ATP. You have other life purposes that we'll talk
about in this whole genetic series. But that is one of your life purposes to make ATP. Whether you know
what or not. So next time you're at a self-development conference and they say, what is your life purpose?
You raise your hand really high and say, my life purpose is to make ATP and you will be the
talk of the seminar. I'm sure. So the way we make ATP is getting ultimately glucose for the
breakdown of carbohydrates, for the breakdown of fatty acids into the mitochondria. So you need
fatty acids and glucose in the mitochondria in order for you to make ATP. That's how you do it. So
that goes through glycolysis. It goes through the crebs cycle. These are limiting factors. These are
oxidants and antioxidants, reducing agents, oxidizing agents in order for these pathways to take
place. And ADH, FADH is a part of this whole process and they're all limited by different genes.
Another picture of the citric acid cycle with a few things to take it out. Whole purpose down here
in the bottom right to make ATP. That's your life's purpose. So we look at your genes and I understand this
page gene is not yet in your profile in the patient's SNP profile. So it's in mine as I look at
people. So I'm partly making some decisions based upon some things you can't see. But it's a very,
this is a rate limited step. The PAKE 1, 2, 3, 4 gene are rate limited steps. They make pentathetic acid
that pushes this pathway. It's all different piece of rate limited steps in this pathway. That's what
we're talking about with these genes. The cardity genes, the SLC genes. Look at how many there are.
And if your gene picture looks like this on your cardity genes, you definitely have rate limited steps
in the ability to get fatty acids into the mitochondria in order to make ATP. Another rate limited
step. So if you could remember that little phrase. These genes in the whole energy pathway,
if I have a lot of defects in any one of these little gene families, it's a rate limited step.
Cardity limits the ability to get fatty acids into the mitochondria for oxidative phosphorylation to
take place, which is supposed to spin out a ton of ATP. So if I have a bunch of defects in this person
would fit into the lot, then that is going to hinder by ability to make ATP. If I have more than this,
you're going to have a lot of hinder ability to make ATP. So inside the cell,
cardity through the OCTN2 gene, or OCTN2 protein made by the SLC gene,
goes into the cell, affects what's called a cardity shuttle in the mitochondria. This is the
wall of the mitochondria to get fatty acids into the cell. If there is a rate limited step there,
meeting that cardity does not able to get fatty acids into the mitochondria very well,
we can see another test. So I can see your genetic profile, like in the last slide, that you have a
bunch of SLCG defects. Oh wow, is that really affecting me? Well, there's other tests that we
could do that we could see are M.I. producing more adipate? Am I producing more ethylmalinate? Am I
producing more subrate? If I am, then this is a huge rate limited step for me. So we use the
a test called the organic acid test, which is another functional medicine test. In this case,
this person see how high their adipate is. They're not getting fatty acids into the mitochondria very
well. They don't have high subrate, not high methylmalinate, but if any one of these three is high,
then that cardatine shuttle is limited. So it can be limited by the genes. You have these SLCG
defects. It can be limited by other things. Let's say I have zero SLCG defects. I haven't seen
anybody has zero, but let's pretend I have zero, but I can have a heavy metal toxicity that's
blocking that cardatine shuttle. Follow me. So when we look at an organic acid test, we say
high adipate, high subrate, high ethylmalinate, then we go, this person is not getting fatty acids into
the mitochondria. Baby, that's a big reason why they got a lot of fatigue. They have to take an
nap, drive it home for work every day. So they have to rely on coffee in order to wake up in the morning.
Or their muscles are sore all the time. Their back hurts all the time. They're going to have to go
to get a juxtapher. They have to go to the massage therapist all the time. They're just sore all the
time. Rate, limiting steps. Got that? Rate, limiting steps. You have to look for if you're going to be
a good doctor. Oh, here's a drug to your take this. Or here's the vitamin take this. Where's the
blockage? Where's the, where's the brakes put on? Where it's not supposed to put on? Where's the
rate, limiting step? Okay? So we look at these genes and we see that. Does that make sense?
Yeah, really rocket science here, right? Another gene is the acat gene. Acat gene.
And let's hear, but be one of the most important ones. Supports the conversion of fats and proteins
into acetylcoids MA. Remember acetylcoids MA is a huge rate limiting step because that's
the first step of the citric acid or the crebs cycle to spin out the spinning around, spinning out ATP.
Your life purpose, right? Acat defects significantly impact that crebs cycle.
So it's going to really limit myocardial function, meaning the function of
producing ATP and you can have influence all the way through your whole body with this.
So super, super important. We see this gene defect a lot. This is a very important gene defect.
So especially with chronic fatigue, chronic line patients that are just wiped out have no energy,
kick it out of bed. Look at the acat genes. Look at that. Supporting that is going to be super, super important.
Okay? So now you know why making specific recommendations on your supplement recommendation list
that you're going to get. Okay? So now you're starting to understand that hopefully. Okay?
Other genes, these other genes in this whole energy function are taking fatty acids
taking glucose, turning them into energy. We have to look at all these different genes, the end
of genes. Now I know in your report you only have the end of seven I think in the patient report,
but there's actually eight different end of genes that we look at. They all have to do with
different what are called complex one, complex two, et cetera of the mitochondrial function. How
it's producing energy, how you're producing ATP. So we're looking at all those genes. Alpha ketoglutarate,
another rate limiting step is the OGTH gene. So we're looking at all that making some recommendations
based upon that. With all this, please, please, please, remember I'm going to hold this at every
slide presentation. I could only make recommendations based upon your genes. So you cannot call the office
and say, well, he made this recommendation, but it says to take three a day. Can I take two a day?
My receptionist is going to go, I don't know. Ask your doctor. I cannot be your doctor. I'm making
recommendations based upon your genes. If you want me to be your doctor, then you have to become a
full patient in our office. We need to start with a case review and we mainly see cancer and really,
really sick line patients in our programs are not cheap. So I put this together to make it very
cost effective for people to get a piece of our help and utilize maybe a piece that their doctor is
missing for, you know, for a fraction of the cost that becoming a patient in our office. But if you
so desire to go the next step, you have to go to our website under this tab called First Steps.
Get it easier and I can make it easier. Follow the steps. Call the office and say I'd like to
become a patient. How much does it cost? What's the cost of the initial case review? It says right on
there what you're going to get an initial case review. So you're not going to get answers to your
questions. That's when I get to interview and see if I can even accept you as a patient. So understand
we're trying to give away as much information as possible. Download my books, watch all my videos,
devour my website. I can't do anymore for that than that. You have to understand the agreements
of the 23 of the agreements. You're going to get a video series, you're going to get your genetic
SNP report and you're going to get a supplement report that's completely solely 100% based upon your
genes and that little questionnaire you fill out. So it's not BB, your full doctor, you have to
understand that. I know you do, you're great. This is what the supplement report's going to look like.
And if honestly it's just, you know, if you do the best you can, if you can't afford all of them,
pick some of them. If you start with them and they make you sick or something, you might have to slow
down. Everybody's body's type is different. I have some patients that only can take a half of each
pill a day to start with until their body is so backed up and so, you know, compromised that they
have to start really, really slow. It's all about taking steps. It's not how fast you go, okay?
It's about taking steps in the right direction. That's what this is about. Thank you very much. I hope
this was enlightening for you. Bye-bye.